[Music]
well hello and good morning from the
Indian Ocean it is our third day in the
deep we have a news site today we are a
hundred and thirty-five meters down that
is 443 feet today though we're not just
on a voyage of exploration we're on a
mission to learn more about where we are
what is down here and what is happening
to the ocean
well our cameras are primed on this
submersible ready to show you around
revealing the life which makes this
place so special
and we're up above on the ship with a
couple of scientists who know that deep
very well indeed and who know their
stuff they've already found some amazing
things while they've been here and
they're ready I hope to answer your
questions
and I'm on algebra [ __ ] the reef that
Anna is exploring is behind me but I'm
on the beach I'll be looking for sea
turtles giant tortoises and a flip-flop
or two and I'm joining the deep ocean
live team today alive from our London
studio sky HQ and I've got some school
children with me from up and down the
country I've got some really pressing
questions for our team in the Seychelles
about climate change biodiversity and of
course sharks yeah and I think that
wants bu Alec as you've seen so many
there where you are we're starting to
call me the shark whisperer here at sky
yeah I know I'm going to bed dreaming
about them I have to say Sarah Jane
lovely to see all the children they're
absolutely brilliant so our mission
today is to give you a never-before-seen
view of this unexplored untouched part
of the Indian Ocean where we are right
now is on a rocky outcrop it is a cliff
face that builds up to our Dabra at all
I was such an enormous at all in the
middle of the Indian Ocean debris is
falling on us right now you could see a
bit in front of the camera there it is
rotting seagrass coming out of the
lagoon at our Thurber it's famous for
this enormous Lagoon you can easily fit
Manhattan Island into that Lagoon and
part of that are dropping on us right
now well here to help guide you through
our journey is my pilot the Aquanaut
Randy holt lovely to see you here the
pilot then of this submersible it's been
a fascinating couple of days thank you
so much for taking us underwater showing
us your world each dive is different and
fascinating but what are you hoping to
to see today as we explore this rocky
outcrop well as you saw as you said
there's a lot of outcroppings here lots
of caves I'm seeing some sea fans here
and we're just gonna see what creatures
come check us out they already starting
to you aren't they lots of questions I
know already coming in for you Roundy
which we'll get to a little bit later
but before we get to those questions
that we've had from you
and the children nasty let's just remind
you where we are because we are
extremely remote
so we've joined these scientists from
the nekton mission in the Seychelles for
a deep-sea exploration of the Indian
Ocean the least explored yet the most
threatened of the world's oceans we're
diving off Aldabra an idyllic at all
nearly 700 miles southwest of the main
Seychelles island of mahi were actually
closer to Africa 400 miles off the East
Coast and around 270 miles northwest of
Madagascar
while the oceans are an entirely fluid
environment it seems like an obvious
thing to say doesn't it but it's a 3d
environment would be moved around all
the time and as we move around there are
key measurements that Randy here has to
do first of all obviously the depth that
has a really big implication if oh hello
I'm just going to see if I can show you
that can go just a little bit further
really fish live it around come down a
bit he's trying to investigate us isn't
it and so our depth can you see him oh
just his tail there we are he's coming
he's coming to see us 443 feet
I can see 444 as we moved there but 444
feet 135 meters the pressure measured in
pounds per square inch is 203 and the
temperature is 20 degrees but it feels a
lot hotter I have to say
we've turned the air-conditioning down
so you can hear us a little bit better
just remind you that you can get in
touch we still want to hear some of your
questions do get in touch using the
hashtag deep emotion light we're all
ready to listen to them broadcasting
obviously on Sky News the Atlantic it's
also on YouTube Facebook as well so
watch us live there mark I know you were
prone last night to tell me that you
have been a little bit deeper than me a
bit of ribbing from you so lovely for me
to be down here again and you to be on
the surface it's lovely to see such a
great picture as well but I was I think
you've already lost we're working with a
great team of scientists from the nekton
mission here as I say on the ship two of
them are with me right here Lucy Woodall
and Ramona Walton tell the children what
you do and say hi hi everyone everyone
back in London my name is dr. Lucy
riddle I'm a senior research fellow at
the University of Oxford and I'm chief
scientist on this expedition so my job
is to make sure the science happens and
to make sure we're collecting all the
amazing information but we're surveying
here with the University of Seychelles
and I'm here part of the science team
looking at the hard corals and
particularly looking at the shadowed in
comparison with the deep so they can
answer really really complicated
questions so make them really hard Sarah
Jane back to you let's get these
questions going
don't worry mark we've got some hard
questions for you and the team
schoolchildren here from four schools up
and down the UK they've got questions
for mark Anna who's down in that
submersible our science correspondent
Thomas Moore and all the scientists out
there in the Seychelles as well I could
see Mark just behind camera looking a
little bit nervous as I said that the
questions are quite difficult let's
introduce the schools it's important to
point out that 1.4 million children took
part in climate change debates and
walkouts last week this is the
generation that really
it's important to have their question
hit questions here this morning first up
let's introduce the children from
Featherston High School in West London
we are joined by twelve and
thirteen-year-olds from new battle high
school in Dalkeith in Scotland they are
also here from princes May primary
school in East London and last but by no
means least from the bold Academy just
down the road from Sky Studios here in
London good morning I mean it's early
it's early right let's also have a chat
with Emily Penn who's our sky oceans
ambassador morning Emily good to have
you with us you're here to fill in any
blanks that we might have here this
morning as well as our team out there in
the Seychelles and why is this deep
ocean Live project so important it's
really about taking people down to these
undiscovered unknown parts of our pilot
planet to find out what's going on we
know so little about the deep ocean and
we know more now about the surface I've
actually been studying plastic on the
surface the last 10 years but there's
this huge gap in our knowledge we know
there's all this plastic going into the
ocean but we're not finding it all up
there so the question is where is it
is it sinking to the deep and that's
exactly what deep ocean life is all
about finding out yeah we'll be finding
out much more about it throughout the
morning Emily thank you I'll let you
take a seat the children are primed and
ready to put their questions to the team
and we don't want the presenters out
there in the seychelles and they
submersibles to have all the fun we're
gonna have a bit of fun our selves here
in the sky studios this morning we got a
mic with a bit of a difference here we
go this is the catch box oh yes I
dropped it quite a few times in
rehearsals children have been doing much
better and let's get our first a
question from the floor we've got
Shakira Shakira stand up and hands off
because you've got a question for the
team here we go
can you describe the ocean in three
words and why
I can't you care a great question
now sorry we lost you internally I think
that as I said I've gone to bed every
night actually having flop shark
flashbacks that actually I'm going to
say scary writing and if I look down
there I would say full boding that's my
I'll give you a different answer if we
were more shallow Randy I described the
ocean probably as a deep blue and life
our life cycle depends on the ocean so
what about Mark back on the ship
mark are describing is very very big
[Laughter]
very scientific can make the planet what
about Thomas I would say it's vast I
would say it's moody - you'd never know
what it's going to do and I think also
it's so important to our planet it's the
life support okay
Thomas Mark and Anna thank you very much
and let's go to the next question and
this is nabila's Shakira a future 8c
Nabila oh these girls are good at
netball right Nabila you're up what's
your question what potential of the
coral have we destroyed
what percentage of coral has been
destroyed well unfortunately quite a lot
it does regrow though I think but I
think was to first to the scientists on
this one Lucy first of all what
percentage of coral has been destroyed
it does it
yeah well I'm actually gonna hand this
to robot yeah so I'm pushing like you
said market is quite a lot it's been
about 30% over the last 50 years and
they predict that we might lose another
30% over the next 30 years so it
unfortunately we are losing our coral
reefs are quite fast rate so the most
important thing is that we research them
we understand them we try and find a way
to protect them better and just very
briefly why are they so important these
roots and the reefs that provide there
like I said before a life support system
okay so they are connected to all of our
ecosystems on land as well and they
support fisheries worldwide so obviously
we all eat fish and in some countries
that is more important as a protein
source and others and our coral reefs
support all of these fisheries as well
okay and Thomas over on the island there
he's seen a lot of coral Thomas what's
your view well certainly if you see the
reef here it is extremely healthy that
it has suffered bleaching in the past
but it has recovered very well now one
of the possible reasons this is the
center an enormous marine protected area
there's no commercial fishing here so
you see an awful lot of fish and they
graze on the algae that would otherwise
a smother they out of the coral when
it's having a tough time there's not a
lot of apex predators out there apex
predators will relate well sharks to you
and me groupers too but mainly the
Sharks and there's a story here now you
too this is Jessica and Alyssa these are
the bones from a humpback whale that
washed into the enormous Lagoon in the
middle in the middle Jessica what
happened to that but those humpback
whales and a year ago like the breach in
one of the China we have on algebra and
we've got two female and a calf that was
got stuck and we try our best to help
them to get back to the water but it was
unfortunately that all of three of them
passed away and they did attract those
some sharks and we've got video of those
sharks what were their sharks what were
they doing and they were feeding on the
remains of the whale and we had tiger
shark and bull shark to
yeah and alissa that was quite a feeding
frenzy wasn't it yeah there are a huge
number of sharks and the whales would
have been a huge food source and
reaching boom for other animals in the
area so there's no wasted opportunity
and there's one of the reasons that
you've got such abundant marine life
around here isn't it yeah definitely
when you when you go swimming in in the
waters here you dive and so on
it is quite extraordinary just how
vibrant the life is yeah definitely I
mean you don't see tiger sharks or bull
sharks when you die but you do see a lot
of other things fantastic thanks very
much both of you so bye team up to speak
to Anna clearly but we've lost
communication I know what that feels
like
thanks very much
mark they gonna be he got an answer
about coral got some sharks in there as
well because we love sharks don't we so
there you go you've got two answers to
your question let's look for Connor
Connors got the next question hands up
Connor perfect Connor what's your
question you've got words of the day
actually this is a nice long one for
this hour of the morning have you seen
any bioluminescent creatures and ozone
and how do they create their own light I
have seen some bioluminescent Crusher
creatures in the dark it's kind of like
when we're driving and there's these
little sparkles of light that come
across the sphere of the stuff as we
move and they create that light
basically when we stimulate them and
down deeper it's a totally another and
it's such an amazing thing isn't it
because in the deep with no light
animals must have special adaptations to
find food to avoid predators to find a
mate and bioluminescence does just that
sometimes they can actually depth charge
light to avoid predators and confuse
them it's an extraordinary thing and in
fact what we have noticed as we come
down here while we're on the subject of
light is that you lose the color red
really quickly so without this light on
I'm actually in a sort of slushy purple
color even though I'm clearly wearing a
pink top so the whole light question is
really interesting sarah-jane and thank
you Connor thank you for that question
Connor from new vacuole hi we've gotten
a beer next Nabire sound up Connor
your turn to throw nobody's dropped it
yet and a beer has a lettuce down a beer
what's your question for the team out
the seychelles just plastic affects life
down in the toilet zone now so that's a
really interesting question because
that's always been the concern hasn't it
that it's micro plastics that are
beginning to fall down and enter the
food chain down here we're moving around
so probably here and Randy doing a bit
of ballast manipulation I say that I did
yeah doing some ballast there in the
tanks and running
what about you have you seen plastic
you've done so much more of this diving
than I have I've dove a lot of coastal
areas and a lot of oceans and yes
sometimes we do see large Nets they're
called ghost nets fishing nets that have
been snagged and left behind are lines
and another marine debris but
fortunately it's been pretty clear down
at depth here yes although we do have
like Marines snow falling I don't know
if you can slightly see it I mean some
of this is the sediment from the lagoon
but this is also some of the plankton
the zooplankton plant plankton it's
absolutely crucial for life down here
and some of the coral that we see is if
we every point up here as we as you stay
on us and all of that is feeding on
plankton so it's really important
serving thank you know be a great
question so the plastic does affect the
Twilight Zone but what about beach level
because we can go to the beach we can
actually see the plastic we can't sit
down the Twilight Zone but we can see on
our beaches and where thomases is around
700 miles from human habitation yeah our
plastic pollution still gets there at
Thomas what have you found on the beach
this morning well it's a quite
extraordinary the amount of plastic
there's being cleaned up here all these
bags were taken off a small stretch 50
meter stretch of beach yesterday by
volunteers for algebra cleanup that's a
group of people partly from Seychelles
Islands foundation but also from the
Queens College Oxford they've got
together because they are so concerned
what's happening in this pristine
wilderness it is really a victim of
geography just in the wrong place that
all the ocean currents bring this
plastic hundreds thousands of miles and
it causes all kinds of problems on the
beaches here not just for the tortoises
but also for the turtles which have to
make their nests and I I saw a turtle
crawling out of a nest the other day and
that was causing huge problems at Thomas
thank you very much well for a bit more
about the plastic pollution and how it
affects our oceans Emily Penn sky ocean
ambassador is with us and Emily it's
really interesting we've got Anna down
in the
deep Thomas up on land and it seems it
doesn't matter where you are when it
comes to the ocean plastic has
infiltrated everywhere
absolutely the fact that our ocean
covers 70% of our planet it really as
Lucy the scientist said it connects us
all and so that plastic wherever it
begins whether it's here in London or
whether it's even in a remote part of
the world eventually it gets into the
ocean and then it moves around our
planet it moves to these gyres these
accumulation zones and that's where we
expect a huge amount of it is sinking
yeah I've got a newfound hatred for
flip-flops I never really liked them and
I'm gonna make a vow never to wear them
again so many of them being washed up on
the beach that we can see let's get back
to the beers question because that was
really interesting remind us when he
wants to because I know Emily's got a
view on this it's plastic affecting life
in the twilight zone
nice I think we can't see it and it's
not like a flip-flop it's much smaller
than that but it's still there it is and
what we're finding is happening at the
surface is that an plankton is growing
on the plastic and barnacles and things
like that and that's what actually makes
it then heavy and it starts sinking so
I'm sort of not surprised that down
there they can't physically see it
because it's probably disguised so until
neck and pull' bring them back to the
lab to study them then we should know
more okay Emily thank you and a beer as
well it's really interesting deep ocean
live we've been doing it for the last
couple of the days and one of the most
horrifying images I've spotted from the
team out there is a flip-flop with
marine life growing on it that's what
they found washed up on the beach and
quite shocking scenes Anna up on the
beach not so bad where you are but it's
still there doesn't mean that it's not
visible to the naked eye that it's not
affecting marine life there
absolutely let's just show you where we
are and you can really sense the rocky
outcrop look how steep that is it's a
cliff wall building up to where Thomas's
on the beach up there it's really been
quite an incredible fir this flan corner
of the Seychelles archipelago 115
islands in total we are by far one of
the remotest Aldabra atoll and from
being on the Anton itself the land that
time forgot it felt totally prehistoric
to here in the submersible I'm lucky
enough to had a permit had a few dives
now with Randy and I say for me part of
the best bits are the journey themselves
from diving when you say dive dive if
having got the clearance from topside
and the whole wall sub tips forward like
that and you go down into the blue and I
expected to see fish straightaway
nothing just blown all the way down
until 70 metres or so down we arrived at
a sandy bottom and the first time we did
it we had dancing fish all around us it
was actually amazing
and then randy says gets permission from
the top to go even from topside to go
deeper and here we are in this deep a
corner you see these sorts of leaves
this is where the fish tried to find
shelter and the predators that all
around them little sea urchins we can
see sometimes enemies sometimes sea fans
those corals we were talking about it's
absolutely beautiful down here
and then the other part for me that's
really extraordinary is coming to the
surface but I think we didn't get me
come on - that's a little bit later in
another question but all of this is so
otherworldly it's hard to describe is
there any chance we can get up to this
wire and whip coral up here we might be
going too high you might lose us but
anyway there's plenty of people to speak
to if you do look at these fronds of
coral you'll begin to see just remember
these are animals and that's what's so
extraordinary they look like little bits
of white sea grass
but these things are you'll gradually
get to them there's another beautiful
bit a diversity fan we're passing there
but you're going to get this current
right we've got current we're gonna have
to drop down quite quickly but we'll
show you and then we'll go down again
there you go you see a bit of white and
the top right hand corner of your
picture that is a living animal
everybody and its tentacles are out it
can't retract them it's trying to eat
plankton tiny little sea urchin right
might as well and for me that there's
living creatures down here they love
this place because they're we're right
on a rocky outcrop we're on a rocky
outcrop here and so they love it here
they're getting all the current that is
coming up but we have seen so many
creatures it's been wonderful to see
them all so let's show you some of the
pictures from the deep
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well it really is an extraordinary
environment and just to remind you
nobody has seen this before I'm going to
show you again the wall we're on we're
investigating the nooks and crannies
down here nobody has been down here most
of the time scuba divers here and
they're not even allowed to scuba dive
along as part of the coast only allowed
to go to about 20 meters where well it's
varying at the moment there we're just
under 135 meters down right now
this has literally been seen by nobody
so nobody knew creatures were here it is
a real privilege certainly to have seen
above land and beneath sarah-jane
yeah and looking all those dark nooks
and cranny's we wonder what's gonna pop
out stay on shark watch for us and we've
also got some more questions for you as
well Randy the pilot as well he wants
his job he's got an Aquanaut yeah when I
grow up I want to be an Aquanaut as well
right let's have a look at some more
questions and a beer on your feet cuz
you're gonna have to hand over the mic
to Dylan now for a new battle hi who's
got a question for Mark Austin and his
scientists excellent where it gets dark
at that
how does vegetation still grow without
delay at the Sun it's a very good
question first of all just a quick one
on bioluminescence I was at 250 meters
yesterday I'm sure I saw a lantern fish
of bioluminescent fish it turned out to
be the headlights of the submarine so
there are disappointments this is a very
good question where it gets dark good
question very little sunlight down there
there is that's right so on the surface
of the water and we've got some corals
we've got algae and seagrass and that
all uses the light through to
synthesizes the coral they've got little
tiny algae inside and they
photosynthesize and help the coral get
energy so that's how everything gets
energy on or near the surface however as
we go down the amount of
and also the type of light changes so
what we do is the animals that live
deeper down change from the light
feeding organisms down to things that
feed off other organisms so all that
means snow we saw on the way down that
is tiny bits of animals that have been
floating down the water column and the
animals that live down there are filter
feeders so they'll pick up things and
their tentacles in the water or maybe
along the seabed and they'll be feeding
in the sediment that's how they survive
yeah I think it's just really important
for us all to understand that plastic is
a challenge because we can see it
there's lots of stuff in our water that
we can't see and there needs to be
research that goes on right now to
figure out you know we've got some
plastics that we know about and we know
certainly with like maybe ghost fishing
gear the impacts of that but lots of
things we still don't know so I mean
it's really important for us to remember
there's lots of unseen dangers out there
and a really great way for us all to
connect with the oceans is those plastic
objects we're using every day there's a
whole heap of other chemicals we use in
our lives we don't have any idea about
their impacts okay point well made let's
go back SJ
many more questions to come I'm sure
yeah many more questions while some mark
is doing the science part we've got a
neuron shark watch we've got Thomas
Moore on the beach on tortoise watch and
I think he's found one yes I have indeed
aren't they amazing there are a hundred
and fifty thousand giant tortoises on
Aldabra I've got two of them here
sheltering from the heat of the Sun I'm
going all David Attenborough on you
they are very docile creatures quite
magnificent there's something very
Jurassic about them they look like
walking living dinosaurs and they are
quite incredible they just flop down at
night and fall asleep exactly where they
are but they are very at risk from all
the plastic that is washing out from
from the ocean and just to to make the
point we've we've got some tortoise poo
here Kelsey just tell us about it so
basically we found this right among the
beach near our weather they're feeding
areas and when we look through it
because they don't have a very efficient
digestive system
just go through and you can see bits of
plastic that have gone through and
presumably flip-flops and which shows
that they are eating
you can see actually more inside there
just to make the point women stage this
at all this really is PO with plastic
insider and that can't have been very
pleasant for the tosses at all it should
not be here and but Craig I mean
wherever you go on tab where you can see
tortoises and they are quite attracted
to plastic particularly the flip-flops
it seems they really are so the team
that I was with we went down to one of
the remotest parts of the atoll in the
southeast and there there are just so
many tortoises you lose count and lots
of talk to his grazing areas just
inundated with plastics particularly
flip-flops all over the place thank you
very much indeed so Jane we found some
tortoises for you bet you thanks very
much Thomas that also is looking very
sleepy there in the midday Sun out in
the Seychelles but we're wide awake
here in the studio we've got some more
questions for the team out in the
Seychelles we had a brilliant one from
Dylan a moment ago at Dylan you're now
handing over to Joel who's from
Featherston hi he's got a question for
Mark Austin and the scientists given
their importance why aren't there more
marine reserves well that is a very good
question and a very good question
addressed to a place like this where
something like 50% of the sea is a
marine reserve
Reserves well I think if we take the
Seychelles context here we can see in
the recent extension of the pre
protected areas but it's really hard
there are so many people who are using
the ocean for a variety of different
uses and to try and get them all to
agree to bring in measures can be really
hard so it's a long process and an
important one but with all these
competing uses we have to find a way to
use that resource sustainably that's
that's the key I think Lucy yeah
absolutely I think that's a really good
point right you know we're sitting here
now it's a beautiful conservation area
but actually you know there was a lot of
people in their lives and their food
security depends on the ocean so we
can't just say we can't take anything
out we need to do that in a sustainable
manner this does take a lot of
consultation because it only works if
you've got buy-in from everyone who uses
that area but it also takes political
well so something we can help to do a
scientist is provide information what's
out there and what areas can be used
sustainably and what is that sustainable
use but also try to understand areas
that actually there are so unique and so
important that really as humans we
shouldn't touch them we should be
looking at other areas that maybe might
regenerate a little quicker yeah well
there we Isis a sensitive sensitive
subject course because fishermen have
their livelihoods and they have to make
a living
thank you very much and now we all
decided pretty early on that when we
grow up now we want to be aquanauts
Randi is piloting and below the ocean
this morning they are sitting there
having a great time exploring new things
down there we've got some quickfire
questions for you let's go to Georgia
Soph the last was just a Joel now has to
hand to Lucy from new battle highs got a
question for Randi how long at one time
are you submerged it really depends on
the mission that we're on if we do a
long dive where we're motoring a lot
exploring a lot using a lot of thrusters
it might only be two or three hours
sometimes we do longer like five or six
but if we got stuck down here we could
stay underwater in the sub for four days
waiting for rescue
thank you for that Randy okay and Lucy
we're handing over to Abbes there for
the next question
how much preparation have you undergone
for this mission
did you hear that one is that for us
he's concentrating on piloting to say
how much preparation have you undergone
for this mission quite a bit there's
been a lot of equipment from a lot of
different people around the world that
we've put together on the sub the
science package that we've installed is
not typical for this vehicle so that's
water sampling that's all kinds of
camera equipment and devices for
measuring the things we see exactly and
also you take a lot of samples don't you
so that's another bit of equipment
you've had to build a tray at the front
of the submersible to try and take those
samples which are very carefully
regulated what you can take yeah that's
correct we have the collection basket
that's taken a little bit of art to get
it to work right and but yeah we can
collect samples from certain depths
based on what the scientists determine
is useful and we'll collect those and
bring them up for them to the lab
our Randi is battling a deep-sea current
which is why he's slightly distracted
he's operating that submersible keeping
them safe let's have our next question
from Jessica from new battle hi Jessica
hands up do you have to decompress after
diver
I know we don't have to Deacon gin the
water column like a scuba diver ocean
current I was talking about not only is
Randy having to navigate through that
but it's also interfering with our
communications as well so while we get
Randy to get the submersible out of that
current we'll go back to Mark who's with
our science panel and Mark it's quite
interesting lots of questions about
what's happening with that submersible
but also we've got lots of questions
here about ocean pollution and you've
actually got some questions from
schoolchildren out there in the sea
shells who are also concerned about
what's happening to the planet around
them yeah of course they are and yes
we've got some questions from
schoolchildren in the Seychelles on the
island of prior Lyn and they're very
good questions as well here is the first
one they've made little videos for us
having found in your adventure so that
was how many kinds of species have you
found in actually the answer right now
is we don't know because we've still
gotta analyze all of these data that
we're collecting and that's a really
important thing for us to be doing over
the next 12 to 18 months but I can say
right now it'll be hundreds we've got
all sorts of things who are corals and
our seagrass and our sponges all the big
stuff but also with all the training
little soup lankton that we've missed
the lettering incidents so I'll be able
to give your proper arms here in about
18 months time so if we can come back
here that's great until then I think
I'll say about a few hundred ok a few
hundred let's get the next question and
the next video from a school child in
the Seychelles well that's a very good
question how are we preventing harm to
algebra from any threats that arise and
and man has been trying to prevent harm
to up there for very long time since the
world Charles Darwin and other
scientists back in 1874 wrote a letter
saying this place should be protected
how are we protecting this place
well the Seychelles Islands Foundation
if you manage out Deborah working
alongside stations government and many
other partners in Seychelles are working
really hard all of the time to identify
those threats and manage them as they
arise so it could be invasive species
it could be climate change it could be
coral bleaching 365 days of the year
they are doing research and they're
trying to understand our diver a bit
better so they can instigate the right
that management actions so definitely
there's a lot of work going on and to
oppose identify those threats and find
the best way to manage them yeah and the
Seychelles government interestingly has
been getting people to pay off part of
the national debt and in return making
more and more of the Seychelles a
protected area Leonardo DiCaprio the
famous actor is one of those guys who
has paid the Seychelle government to do
that let's get another question thank
you very much this next question is for
Anna in the Saab hopefully we can speak
to her with reestablished coms and let's
get the question from ramza who's from
prince's may here we go another throw
nailing the throwing this morning I'm
catching well done guys if you could
speak to sea creatures what would you
ask
oh you know what I would ask is do you
feel fear because this is all about
predator and prey from what I've seen
here it's all about trying to avoid
being eaten you know as I said earlier
the little caves that we're seeing right
now I'll show you some of them they're
all hiding in there some some of these
little creatures and we know especially
around here the black tip reef sharks
they come out at night they're nocturnal
think they're nocturnal feeders what
they need to do is use their senses and
like the sense of smell and they sense
electromagnetic movements as well
which we see if we can get you can see
the tail of the sailfish is back again
so really it's very interesting actually
a lot of the life of these sea creatures
is trying to avoid being eaten so do you
feel fear what about you your question
my question to the sea creatures you
know what they think of us being down
here yes and there is a sense of reverse
aquarium isn't there actually it's
really interesting because they actually
come right close to us we had a potato
group of the other day that stayed with
us and while we ascended for about 200
feet it stayed with us and in fact you
were talking to it I seem to remember
and you weren't you yeah it came right
up to the sphere and was actually almost
like it was kissing the acrylic
so we are aliens in their world and they
come to say hello it's been absolutely
fascinating I don't know if they've got
an answer there and the surface to that
to that question thank you very much a
lot of those fish looking very Burmese I
think marks got a question got an answer
to that question mark if you could speak
to sea creatures what would you ask them
I think I'd ask them what they think
about a bottom disturbing their Kip this
morning but they are amazing pictures
and I mean astonishing pictures and
you've just got to keep pinching
yourself it's you know it this is never
been done before and also that 94% of
life on this planet any life on this
planet
94% exists under where we are now in the
ocean so what's your answer the question
if you could speak to a sea creature
what would you say I'm gonna weigh more
than one but and I guess I'm just
limited to one today and I think I would
ask them and ask them about their
behavior so you who they hang out with
where they go these are the sorts of
things you know where they go because we
don't we've already done that for such a
short snapshot of time we can only see
them for that period of time so be
really cool to say
where do you go we sometimes have
information from tags which gives us
longer turn data but for those smaller
creatures that's not possible so that's
what I would ask Ravana well that would
be a dream come true if I could speak to
sea creatures so I hope that might
happen and if I could I'd probably ask
them how could we make your lives better
I think you know we have so many impacts
on our ocean so I probably want to ask
them what can we do for you how can we
make things better for you yeah pretty
sure the fish would say cut out
single-use plastic that's probably what
they'd say Ella is here with us and Ella
is one of the presenters of fYI the
children's program here on Sky News
every weekend hello Ella and you've got
a question yeah from what you've
discovered what would your message be to
children around the world who is that
too
oh is it to me and good question well
part of the reason that skies and rescue
decided to focus on plastic was that
because we can all contribute more
certainly we can all decide not to use
plastic straws we can all use a reusable
bottle so I think if we think about
taking baby steps to a bigger goal I
think that's always a great philosophy
in life so let's all take more baby
steps if at home you're watching this
and you decide to walk to work and
perhaps turn the heating down a bit then
we're all doing as much as we can at
that point always build to doing more
and I think really actually that this
marine environment is so special it is
so amazing that we all deserve to do a
better job for it and certainly the
evidence of that is on Aldabra atoll as
thomas moore is finding out so starkly
wash up on algebra at all there is no
great human settlement here these are
coming hundreds if not thousands of
miles brought here on the ocean currents
there are 2 billion people living around
the Indian Ocean clearly this is cheap
Footwear it's Bob we're people we're in
hot countries but sadly these countries
do not have good Waste Management so
these flip-flops leak out into the ocean
and of course they are buoyant they
float on the surface and that's why so
many end up here in fact there are so
many that I found it quite easy to find
a pair for myself just to wear on the
beach while we've been making this
program but I'm joined by two people are
being trying to clean up the mess that
we as human beings are leaving Craig
e-beam doing an awful lot of work on the
south coast of algebra which is prime
turtle nesting territory that's correct
so they've been 12 of us who've been
deployed down to the South various camps
and we've just been tackling this issue
we've just been trying to get as much
marine debris of turtle nesting beaches
and talk to his grazing areas as
possible already we've done just over 20
tons we're pushing for more over the
next week and a half but there's a lot
of stuff this is not even representative
this is a drop in the ocean of what
we've been doing down south yeah when
you see an or third of fishing this I
hear you saying cigarette lighters but
flip-flops
do take take out quite a lot of the the
overall weight you're hoping to clean up
something like 5060 thousand flip-flops
that's correct yeah there are so many
flip-flops down there one of one of the
things that we do here is they can take
your own pair of flip-flops back there
are so many so yeah there are so many
flip-flops
Josie I mean you're concerned well you
had a good what else these flip-flops
might bring just show us because these
things are floating on the ocean you can
end up with marine life latching onto it
where they start off and then it can
float here and that can sort of bring
invasive species here that can cause a
lot of problems so these are invasive
species I know they're not flood of
concern about a sponge a marine sponge
that has all come all the way from Guam
and the Pacific to here I mean I hadn't
heard that's terrifying to hear but it
makes a lot of sense I mean like when
you sail around here you can see things
bobbing in the ocean and saf here have
an amazing biosecurity protocol they
check our shoes they fumigate everything
but they can't stop you know
we've you know thousands and thousands
and thousands of flip-flops that are
bringing these things across the ocean
so it's scary yeah it's a real message
they're something to really take home
and do something about so let's just
react to this and back to you and Sarah
Jane yeah it's incredible isn't it
Thomas I mean we've all lost a flip-flop
in the scene you think I've lost my
flip-flop I'll buy another pair but
that's where it ends up really
disturbing things I think most
disturbing statistic for me today is
that every year the amount of plastic
that goes into the ocean is the
equivalent weight of the human
population on this planet that's
absolutely incredible and but there you
go flip-flops washing up there which is
700 miles from human habitation the
effects of plastic pollution really do
reach far and wide we could have another
question now for Anna down there in a
submersible with Randy and this question
is from Jennifer from new battle hi here
we go what's the weirdest type of
species you've found on the water you
mean apart from those wire and whip
corals we showed you which are actually
alive and they look like they're a bit
of vegetation don't they the weirdest
ones I think some of the scientists has
seen have to be the sunfish it was about
2 meters big Louise saw it up she's on
the on the ship right now at 200 meters
and I think they're the weirdest things
I sort of swim around like this and the
potato grouper who follows up to the
surface and actually wanted to show he
was intelligent lifeform with us
the weirdest things I've seen are things
that don't look like anything you've
seen before these jellies that glow and
they form these colonies and you know
they might be the size of something like
that but they're all little small
organisms absolutely amazing I mean it's
wonderful to see all of this and I a
mark went even deeper obviously as you
continue to remind me to 257 meters I
don't know what you saw down there that
that tickled you didn't see many weird
fish but I saw something that I felt was
very weird and I feel the scientists say
no no no it's normal but we were just
going up to a rock and suddenly a
lobster came out looked very much like a
lobster just came out of a tiny little
sort of cave the lobster a normal place
to find obstinate
I think it's really interesting because
when we talk about weird things I think
that a difference worse and as where
everything is and we live on the surface
of the water most stuff looks weird to
us down there of course it's just
evolved to live in that way and have
that special shape and live in a certain
way because it's underwater so I don't
know what I think weirdest things I
think all things like the angler fish
they're pretty cool because they've got
their own lure so they've got this
little thing that comes off the top of
that head is often lit up and this helps
attract prey to them that's pretty neat
it's pretty weird we don't run around
with the lures on our heads getting
things that come into our mouth that's
pretty neat
I think also anything similar to what
Lucy said I think it's when my favorite
thing underwater is when animals and
camouflage themselves to look exactly
the same as the hosts they're living on
so you might have a crab living on a
soft coral fan and it's evolved over
time to look exactly the same that to me
it's not maybe weird but I think it's so
clever and so unique that those
organisms have evolved like that all
right well we've got another question I
think coming now for you two on plastic
let's go back to Sarah Jane and get the
next question yeah thanks mark a weird
and wonderful world of the deep ocean we
know more about the moon than we do
where than where Anna botting and Randi
are right now and let's have a question
from Krupa who's from Featherston hi
Jennifer if you want to throw over to
creeper how many years would it take to
remove all the rubbish from the ocean
well that is a good question
okay how many years would it take to
remove all the rubbish on the ocean I'm
going to guess and say what you could
you're right we can't remove all the
rubbish that's being put into the ocean
I mean that's enough not possible some
of it is still on the surface of the
water but majority is fragmented and
down at the bottom so rather than
concentrating on the removal we need to
concentrate on stopping the tap stop it
getting into the ocean that's gonna be
the most success for us and most of the
plastic is too many tiny bees that have
sunk to the bottom anyways see you
bedded in the coral that's right yeah a
lot of it's on the seabed so we just
can't remove it yeah it's amazing
pictures Ranna what was your view on
remove
exactly the same is Luci Ruby um is the
prevention it's all about prevention now
large-scale removal will be an effective
probably at this point and as you said
quite rightly obviously microplastics is
so much more of an issue now that's in
our food chain so that's much more of an
issue so it's more about now stopping
that flow of plastics into the ocean
yeah so it's for the next generation to
start looking after the ocean better
than we did maybe back to us Jane yeah
mark is really interesting I mentioned
earlier over a million children across
the globe demonstrated about climate
change last week so this is the
generation that really cares and they
want to do something about it Emily Penn
sky ocean ambassador is still with us
and Emily it's interesting hearing there
from the scientists that we may never
what we will never get all the plastic
out of the ocean but what we can do is
stop putting more in there exactly I
mean even if we were successful with
getting it out if it's still going in
eight million tons every year then we're
never going to solve the problem so it
does or lie in prevention and thinking
mostly about our own personal
consumption of plastic and we need to
pass on plastic we need to eliminate
that single-use plastic from our lives
so it doesn't end up on that little
island in Aldabra or on the bottom of
the ocean top tip on what everyone
watching at home can do because a lot of
people go oh well what I do won't make a
difference but if everybody makes that
little bit of effort in their everyday
lives become absolutely and plastic bags
plastic bottles coffee cups those are
all the place to start and we think that
it's just one bottle but it's these
micro actions that really add up
okay micro actions that is the call to
action Emily thank you final question
from dawn and this is for Anna down in
the submersible here we go heads up
what is the process for naming new life
if discovered in the twilight zone and
do you bring it to the surface for
further study goodness me I don't know I
don't think there is yet an arc Austin
lobster but I'm sure he'll be fighting
for that as well as the deepest person
ever there to be in this part of the
Indian Ocean certainly and but certainly
one of Lucy's colleagues at nekton has
three things named after him professor
Alex Rogers they're very interesting
interesting animals certainly but would
you would you like something they'd love
to do I'd like to have something named
after me I don't care what it is it's
been absolutely fascinating experience
being down here I have to say it's
wonderful to hear the questions there
from the schoolchildren it's interesting
the types of questions you're asking as
we show you the vote the view into the
gloom if you like what has been the most
interesting for me is that this is a
world that is totally unexplored that
literally nobody knew what was down here
off Aldabra nobody even knew the shape
of the coastline we've been able to show
with the nekton scientists they the
slopes shareholds off so steeply as we
can show you there it is extremely
foreboding you look down and it's a sea
Enki color and you literally don't know
what's down there the fish are around us
they're trying to come and say hello
there's still life down here it's
critical life as well because the big
question is is this a refuge if the Seas
get warmer and the calls down here
survive can some of them move into
cooler water down here 20 degrees
certainly down here and our Deborah
atoll itself it is a world unlike any
other there are frigate birds flying
over there not like pterosaurs there are
giant reptiles walking along and it is
extraordinary to see the two things
together amongst the best protected part
of the world as around here tries to
keep us in position we're swinging
around in the currents because they've
come right up to the rocky outcrop we
are now facing the deep let me show you
what we can see there you go that is the
deep ocean everybody but that is what
you're fighting for there are fish out
there who need the shallows they need
the shallows for juveniles to feed to
prey absolutely crucial deep ocean life
has been an extraordinary experience for
me I hope you've enjoyed it thank you so
much for watching from the deep goodbye
[Music]
it's an extraordinary place to be I have
to say
amazing I just can't believe that we're
seeing you and hearing you like this
why for cars from some pretty remote and
amazing places in my time but none quite
Sarah mobile remains
[Music]
stuff the coast of this amazing island
behind us here called Aldabra what they
call the Galapagus of the Indian Ocean
after the famous island of great
biodiversity at the Pacific island it
really is the most wonderful place and I
mean if you were watching in the last
hour we really have the most wonderful
hour of television from the deep where
Anna was in the submersible and from the
island just across here and I can see
actually where Thomas Moore our science
correspondent was talking to you from
and from scientists here on the ship but
most of all the stars of the show were
the schoolchildren back there who were
asking really really interesting
questions which were some of them a
great fun and others actually flawed
almost flawed the scientists here they
were they were so good my hope and pray
that we can still see and hear and know
down there because I've got to say that
was a wonderful job you did down there
Randy well done the pictures were
amazing I mean just amazing to show
schoolchildren images like that a life
like that that they will probably never
see for themselves which is the great
shame in this but they will see on
television and you did that you brought
them to us and thank you very much and I
mean you know just carry on the way you
were going I mean it was so fantastic
show us some more of those wonderful
pictures down there I think we're
getting that way at the way you know the
currents tricking us that way we are
fighting to stay in line with our
communication system which is right
above us at the moment but if you lose
this it's because we're right at the top
of this rocky outcrop I can't quite show
you because if we do we probably so
we're taking shelter behind this wall if
we swing around normally or the other
I'm not sure we can sort of show you how
steep it is but above us there is
literally an overhang and it's giving us
the shelter which is exactly what we
need to stay in one location is quite
difficult and certainly Randy throughout
the hour has been fighting our location
quite quite tricky few actually
let's meet Ricky yeah there's a the
currents here have been really
unpredictable every single day and even
within the hour we've been down here it
changes from going up the wall to down
the wall
it's hard yes and certainly we tried to
do all this science work on the south of
algebra and actually we sent down the
remote camera I couldn't get past about
30 meters could it so it's very
difficult I mean how could you say 420
feet that's about 135 meters about 135
meters so we've been hovering around
this area try to see as much as we can
see but I know Sarah Jane you've still
got schoolchildren with you and
practiced I've got a few more questions
for
famille or even better for Andy yeah
trust me Anna they've been glued to the
screens and they're in no rush to leave
and go to school
let me tell you that how much did we
enjoy that last hour hands up who wants
to tell me about their favorite bits or
has got a question for the guys below
okay here we go ready yes we haven't
dropped one yet my name's Kieran Joe and
I would like to ask you what would be a
future mission Oh Randy that sounds like
it's Veera Aquanaut
a future mission a good future mission
I love diving on shipwrecks as well so
you know that's always exciting for me
and just go into new places like this
this is somewhere where nobody has gone
before so it's really exciting to see
something new and be working with the
science and the teams and how how deep
have you ever been the deepest I've gone
is one kilometer deep that's a thousand
meters or over 3,000 feet and that was
in the Bahamas also in a Chinese
submersible can you turn around and show
everyone the deep ocean again yeah
because it's all very well saying oh I'm
just going down I'm gonna follow a nice
bit of rocky outcrop down to the bottom
be fine but actually a lot of when we
drop down is literally just blue there
we go we'll get away from the rock yeah
yeah well there we are that's what
happens when you try to move in the
submersible down there that's what
happened to me yesterday when we tried
to move we had a good fixed position
then we tried to move and it's very
difficult because I'll tell you how they
do it these submersibles send out LED
light since it's going up to what's
called a receiver a depressor that sort
of hovers above you so when you move it
causes problems and that receiver then
sends by cable the images that you saw
there are the wonderful images after the
mothership that we're on and then off by
traditional means by a satellite which
just beams it off to you
I just want to ask Lucy Woodall who's
still here some of those pictures we
were seeing at the beautiful corals just
describe what we were seeing there
because that was life that was that was
a different world
the inhabitants of a different world
wasn't it absolutely so everything that
lives down there is there because of you
know the type of light the temperature
the amount of nutrients in the water
some of them impacted by are the other
animals that live around them so each
the community we come across is unique
and that's really exciting and that's
really what we're here as scientists to
figure out what lives there and why do
they live there and then what do they do
how are they impacting on our lives and
on the lives of our light beings so the
things that we will be able to see I
things like the beautiful wit corals and
those wonderful white wires going up
there see them there yeah exactly we can
see some urgence as well we can see
regular actions with sort of quite thin
spines and sometimes we see pencil
urchins they're the ones with the
thicker spines it's a little fish what
do we got there
I've just floored a scientist I love it
also we've got coming up here we've got
little bits of coral you got some algae
you're a beautiful fan coral there
underneath the outcrop as well so these
pictures are very useful for you is you
just in what way do you use these sort
of images and what weight is the
information that you're getting right
now from these pictures where you know
people haven't been before
yes so it's very important for us to be
able to quantify that and what we do is
we run the submersibles along a line
which is into which we call to transact
about 250 meters and then we watch to
see the animals both the fish and the
things living on the sea floor the
benthos that's our word of the day and
and when we see what's there and how
that changes so we measure it multiple
times at multiple depths and then look
how that changes from the surface down
to depth so we've seen today some of the
animals that are living down deep upon
the surface we'll see some of those I
really I connect corals you might think
opal probably and actually as we get
down deeper we're gonna see different
animals like the ones you saw down at
250 meters like mostly the urchins some
of the sea cucumbers to identify and
organize these into the zones is really
important because each of these
communities are very different they can
they all live in the same water column
but they are actually quite different so
for us to be able to appropriately
manage these waters we need to really
understand about them and how they are
connected okay now the school children
who were asking those questions and they
were brilliant question what would you
say to them now if they were watching
pictures like this and felt inspired the
marine science was something they wanted
to get into what would you say to them
listening to you now about the work do
you do and how they could possibly you
know do something similar one day you
know I would say to everyone even if you
know marine science isn't your thing
though out there may be curious ask
questions try and seek answers because
that's what we do that's what we're here
we were like wonder what's there and
then we came out here and looked at it
of course it's not quite that easy
there's a lot of preparation a lot of
hard work we have to be very persistent
but I think it's that curiosity that's
really exciting so there are a lot of
programs in and around our coastal areas
that are pretty easy to get into and
just going out for a walk on the beach
looking in rock pools but people what's
around you if you don't live near the
beach you look in the park there's
amazing birds and amazing things that
live just in our parks in our cities so
it doesn't exclude anyone just go out
there ask questions and be curious I've
got a question for you
we spend so much money on exploring
space where we don't know there is life
and yet we don't spend much money on
exploring somewhere where we really do
know there is life do you think we've
got our priorities
slightly wrong so to be fair we do use
some of the technology that's used in
space down in the deep sea obviously as
a marine biologist this really needs
more spectrum on the deep sea and of
course we've seen here today just a
snapshot of what can be seen which is
equally as exciting and as inspiring and
I think the thing that space had going
for them is it was exciting it catches
everyone's imagination so maybe we've
gone from that space race generation
maybe you're wearing the Ocean Race now
yeah those are amazing pictures new just
seeing I have to say DC thanks very much
the time being don't leave us just yet
let's go back and join Sarah Jane and
London questions from here in the studio
because they're taking Lucy's advice be
curious ask questions you could be an
oceanographer with that those skills
when you grow up or a journalist or as
Mark Austin is proving this morning you
can combine the two skills right who's
got a question about tortoises here we
go let's have it let's have the mic over
here are you ready guys that first start
we've had this morning and it's on a
teacher's head that was not planned
you've all got detention you could have
to stay here for at least another 50
minutes this is for Thomas Moore our
science correspondent who's with a
tortoise what's your question
how long can a tortoise live up to oh
goodness me that's a really good
question several decades I was at there
a research station here on algebra and
there was a huge tortoise called biscuit
the French word for biscuit and he had
been alive for for many many years and
he was huge much bigger than the one you
can see sleeping under the bush here and
they are quite numerous they just
everywhere on this island and there's
supposed to be a cave somewhere in the
middle I haven't been been there myself
but I've been told by Rangers that you
can see and as the heat builds during
the day that there are streams of
tortoises going to this cave and they
pile one on top of each other several
layers just to get into the shade
there's so much cooler in there than it
is out in the tropical heat but of
course all of them are
connected to the sea this is a coral
atoll everything living on land is
connected to the sea and that's why
there is so much concern about the way
they're eating the plastic that washes
up on the beaches that is plastic inside
tortas poo that will have passed all the
way through a tortoise and there have
been instances where people see a whole
flip-flop inside tortoise poo just think
about that Sarah Jane yeah really
disturbing Thomas thank you that poor
tortoise trying to have a nap in the
afternoon Sun and Thomas Moore comes
along with a microphone got a question
from Harris for Anna who's in the
submersible Harris stand up good chest
pass play netball no oh we shared you're
very good Harris what's your question
for Ella how do you know you had
identified a new species or not that's a
really difficult question when it comes
to coral what we've seen down in the
submersibles is people like Randy very
carefully take a sample they take it up
to the surface and then the scientists
get it really quickly so it doesn't
degrade and they take it into the
laboratories and they put it in ethanol
to preserve it and then what they're
gonna have to do is actually go back to
pictures in museums to try to ascertain
exactly what that is a number of corals
have been misidentified it could be do
that and that coral piece they have has
never been described before it could be
something new but it's very very
difficult something like coral which is
some of the main things we're seeing
down here some of the soft curls it's
very difficult to know and certainly
what the scientists and Lucy up on there
on deck will be able to tell you this
they're going to take this information
back and spend many many months
analyzing the pictures that Randy's
taking out all of this is being recorded
every time we show your pictures being
recorded they're analyzed it frame by
frame to see what's down there and
they'll trying to work out exactly
they found on a previous nekton mission
to Bermuda they certainly had more than
a hundred new species that's very
exciting when that happens perhaps some
mark that's something that Lucy can feel
it fit in the gaps for us there yes so
there we are Center potting so mark that
what she just said out of ten for us
good you always be listening to us Anna
yes so as described there there's a lot
of processing that goes on but
essentially what we need to do is to
figure out what we did what we've seen
is different to what is because already
we described now with our work in the
marine realm a lot of things that we
find in new to science because we really
haven't been looking at for very long so
wouldn't surprise me that if 50 maybe 60
percent of what we find here is new to
science I don't know I'm just making a
guess but it is really important for us
to document is what is here and actually
that some of Bro hands work Rana is
looking at the coral collection facility
here in Seychelles and she's going to be
performing a collection of the hard
corals that are found in Seychelles
to act as a baseline for scientists in
the future so this is a really important
stuff that's right Thank You Lucy so
yeah at the university stations we're
actually set up an archival collection
so we're collecting these small
chorim's just fragments of the main
qualities and then trying to archive
them so we have a record so it's really
important to have something to go back
to so know that what we have here and
then also at the future to come back to
that connection so in inventory almost
all the hard coral species that we have
these samples that you take they will be
staying here in say shows yes so we are
housing them at the University of
stations for now and we will be trying
to grow that collection as much as we
can over the next few years
[Music]
yeah the children are standing by with
more questions mark well I've got two
Simon Boxall oceanographer and Emily
Penn who's been with us all morning at a
sky ocean ambassador and Simon it's
interesting watching Anna down in that
submersible and one of the children
asked a really good question earlier on
she asked her describe at the ocean in
three words in fact everyone who's out
in the Seychelles dear and one of the
words that kept coming up was vast it's
so big but put it into perspective for
us because what Anna's looking at looks
vast but actually it's only a tiny
portion of that area if you divide that
the ocean up so every person on the
planet there was seven billion people
had their two meter deep swing fall then
every person on the planet would own at
93 square miles square kilometers of
ocean so as enormous you wouldn't see
your nearest neighbor obviously you want
to get in early so the real estate at
the surface and Seychelles is worth more
than the deep stuff but actually they're
coming down 100 meters hundred 20 meters
that's less than about three percent of
the average depth of the ocean and it's
about a tenth
sorry it's about one percent of the
deepest part of the ocean so you know we
really are looking at the surface skin
if you'd ask the marine biologist 50
years ago what exists in the ocean they
say not a lot today we know even the
deep ocean is teeming with life in us an
amazing place yeah I mean why is it so
important for projects like deep ocean
life to go down as far as we can and
explore I think for me having spent ten
years at sea exploring our ocean the
thing
so key for me was actually falling in
love with our blue planet being
completely mesmerised by understanding
the science of why it was so important
but also just the feeling that it gives
and this exploration is so important
because you know we're showing a part of
the world that's never been discovered
before but hopefully we're also getting
people to fall in love with it because
you really only care for the things that
you love and you only love the things
that you really know yeah well I think
testament to that is Anna botting who's
down in the sub with our Akron or Randi
I'm not sure if she's gonna come back
she's really fallen in love with the
ocean Emily I know you've got a question
for Anna down there in the sub I do I
mean we've had so many great questions
already I can't top those but what I'm
wondering is you know what could you do
that's gonna top this you've explored a
place of the planet that really so few
people have ever had the chance to do so
I mean what's left from here
well go deeper or go higher so let's do
one at the top of Everest or something
like that shall we
that's a really good question because I
just want to at this point give a shout
out to everyone who's made this possible
not only the pilots Randy and Robert
you've helped us all the surface team
everybody at nekton who's been
absolutely amazing the people who
invented the blue comm system were using
and we're drifting underneath the plates
with the question there but also our
engineers at sky it's taken a year to
plan if you work out that most of the
marine documentaries you watch on
television take four to five years to
make we're trying to show you something
in an hour or an hour and a half as it
is today it's very very difficult
the technology is bonkers in many
respects and so I think for now this is
enough that it's worked at all even when
we came on air on Monday morning we
weren't 100% sure it was going to work
like this so it's been an extraordinary
experience but I do want to say thank
you to everybody who's made its property
made it possible
yeah okay that honor it's been an
incredible three days and Simon Emily
thank you for the moment I just want to
go back to Thomas Moore who's on the
beach some 200 meters above where Ana is
and Thomas we've been exploring the
worst offenders when it comes to plastic
pollution on beaches and we always think
of plastic straws plastic bottles
lighters but flip-flops we've discovered
are on that list as well yeah absolutely
I've been all over the world for ocean
rescue as you know over the last two and
a half years and I've seen an awful lot
of plastic but I've never seen so many
flip-flops in one place see we reckoned
this pile that were sitting on about 800
flip-flops and they were cleared from
three beaches no more than 50 meters in
length and these are beaches where green
turtles come up to nests they're having
to wade through that plastic and yes
they we as I arrived on the beach we saw
hatchlings making their way down to the
sea unfortunately there was no plastic
in the way but just imagine what this
pile would mean to a turtle hatchling it
almost certainly mean a barrier that
meant death awful
so Lindsay Turnbull Lindsay is a
professor Oxford University and also a
trustee of Seychelles Islands foundation
the the organization that runs algebra
what do you think when you come here and
you see so many flip-flops well it
breaks my heart
frankly you know this is such an
incredible place and and super seen in
every way been so heavily protected
people have worked so hard to do that
and to find the world's rubbish just
drifting onto its shores is truly
mind-boggling your volunteers have done
amazing work over the past few is clear
particularly carrying up the south coast
where there's many many more flip-flops
but also more turtles nesting which is
why you've focused your attention there
and whatever you do though it's only
scratching the surface because you know
that the next tide will bring in yet
more plastic yet more flip-flops so what
is the long term solution well the long
term solution we have to turn off the
tap somehow we have to do that and
that's beyond the scope of this
particular project but we know for sure
that this cannot stay here so we still
consider that it's been very worthwhile
to get this stuff off here but yes we're
hoping to use this to motivate the rest
of the
world to solve this problem in a much
more sensible way and you're trying to
get this this plastic into something
that you could do some legacy of this
mission something that you could really
show to people that this is not on that
you need to do something about this as
you say turn off the tab that is the
long-term solution the message from
algebra is that it is a victim of
geography it may be isolated but not
isolated enough from the mismanagement
of plastic back to you okay Thomas thank
you and it's been an incredible three
days here as part of deep ocean live and
and it really is groundbreaking stuff
mark Austin is now with the man behind
this incredible mission yeah thanks very
much Sarah Jane all of us deeds is here
what did you make first of all of the
questions that were asked and the way
the children they seem so enthusiastic
about and I think your children watching
it all from the studio yeah my girls
were and I saw a couple of pictures of
them and they were very happy I nearly
had it see for seven weeks undertake
this vision but it's been yeah it's been
a great show congratulations to Sky for
pulling this all together and hopefully
has had some impact it's giving me an
idea for we need to do next so my own
business wise which is next time we need
to have kid we need have young people
and kids in the stops talking to other
young people young people talking to
young people about that experience and I
think could be even more transformative
and let's run do that next time yeah I
mean it's interesting point because
we've been down Anna's down at the
moment we've been down
and it's a very rare thing to get to see
I mean we were the first people you know
to see this stuff and it's extraordinary
how soon do you think it will be a more
common and more routine thing of the
children can go down and see them I hope
you know I hope there will be more
opportunities we know just how expensive
it is the Lord submission like this
we're a small charity we've been able to
pull it off you look at who else does it
it's government its military it's big
research institutes around the world and
it's offshore on a gas so it is
constantly but I think yeah we've got to
look at how much is being spent in outer
space and look at the critical needs to
explore in a space our ocean and sea
actually yeah where should we be putting
the investment I think more of it should
be coming here into the deep sea right
now we've been you know on the boat
about a week where our programs are
almost done when we leave
you'll breathe uh huge sigh of relief no
doubt but also but also but also you'll
get down to the real business so just
tell us what is that business what do
you get down to what we've got what is
the mission for you so we will be
continuing our research operations and
that it's a mix of different activities
we use our submersibles the survey work
to take those video transects you've
seen down there but also for sampling
and then we have an ROV that goes even
deeper as well as that goes down 300 500
metres we've got an incredible survey
boat with our partners from Bibby and
Teledyne marine so with that we're able
to go and cover the sea burns on to map
the seabed take more samples continuous
we create this baseline of how the
oceans changing here around so it's not
okay Oliver thanks very much indeed our
time is nearly up so let's go back from
here in the Indian Ocean beautiful day
beautiful site about that bruh let's go
back to you in London and mark thank you
very much well there you go the man
behind this groundbreaking mission wants
to put children in the sub for his next
mission who's volunteering yeah few
volunteers will pass on your names that
is the next mission here on deep ocean
life thank you very much for your
questions they've done a grand job today
I got a hand to Anna for one final time
before we bring her up to the surface
Anna
thank you very much indeed naturally I
can see weirdly the outline of the ship
right above us the ship's captain has to
keep exactly above us or this doesn't
work the crew done an extraordinary job
doing that but we've been on a mission
with nekton five to five hundred meters
is the deep exploration they want to do
it's been an extraordinary experience I
have to say - to do this with the help
of people like Randy to see all the
little today for me it's been the
urchins I have to say to see the little
urchins were clinging on they can move
it's amazing isn't it what they can do
but I think deep ocean life perhaps has
lifted a lid on the world that we cannot
see this is a world that is alien to
humanity and the problem is out of sight
out of oversight and it doesn't perhaps
get the care that it needs it doesn't
get the marine protection areas and
certainly the Seychelles government has
done an amazing job trying to protect
areas like this areas that are pristine
one last look at the cliff face that
rolls up to Aldabra atoll it rolls up to
that extraordinary environment there
with the giant tortoises and the Turtles
and the robber crabs all fighting for
life everybody fighting for a chance to
survive and the problem of course of
global warming is that corals like we
have seen the corals also up further
higher up in the in the sunlight area
they're really under threat and perhaps
now we need to just take a step towards
trying to protect them and all of the
sea creatures here so from all of us
from you thank you thank you for
watching goodbye
[Music]
it's an extraordinary place to be I have
to say
it's amazing I just can't believe that
we're seeing you and hearing you like
this
some pretty removed and amazing places
in my time but none quite so removed
were amazing
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]